it's not mental health it's low IQ it's
low IQ because they're too stupid to
realize that they're getting lied to
nobody here Pearl's dead on if you put
your phone down and had a real life and
how real things going for you mental
health will go out the window wait so
are you relating with a low IQ I think a
lot of the people that buy into
like people that buy into the
and they get told that they have a
health problem when really they're just
fat and have a life if they turn
their life around their mental health
problems would likely go away no I mean
but like someone so say someone says
like yeah I'm dealing with depression if
someone came along and said that would
you relate that then to low IQ
no I think falling for it and believing
that oh yeah yeah of course you're not
putting a bad mental health state and a
low IQ you know I would call that person
probably lazy right because they're
depressed because they have a life
yeah